whether you get here by car train or
plane every month and sometimes even
twice a month the entire parliament
decamps from brussels to strasbourg for
twelve four-day plenary sessions a year
that's one president some five thousand
meps staff and officials as well as
truckloads of documents so what's all
about time to take a closer look
it's a tailor to cities enshrined into
eu law historically parliament's formal
seat is here in strasbourg but a second
seat was built in brussels so that
parliament with its increasing powers
could be closer to both the commission
and the council brussels is where all
the day-to-day groundwork and votes in
committee to get proposals up and
running takes place and one of the
things decided in brussels is the agenda
of the plenary and that happens here
behind these closed doors at the
conference of presidents it consists of
president schultz the chairman of the
seven political groups of the parliament
and a member of the non-attached members
is allowed to sit on the meeting but
doesn't get a vote with the agenda
decided it's over to strasbourg
the plenary session is anything but a
walk in the park the agenda is packed
with visits of heads of state discussing
breaking news stories and where the
award ceremonies for the lux and sakura
prize take place but its main function
is to serve as the arena for the big
decisions to adopt delay or kill off
legislation and that all starts here in
the hemi cycle with long hours spent
debating
on the agenda will be four or five
dossiers expected to face a vote the
next day and so meps along with
representatives from the commission and
council discuss and present their final
positions this is also where political
groups can table last-minute amendments
to a draft proposal meps have a lot of
speaking times during debates and
sometimes if they run over
israel
and exchanges can become quite heated
i'm certainly not going to lose much
sleep over this
over to the next day when those same
dossiers are put to a full plenary vote
so claude can you take us through the
whole process it's a bit of a marathon
isn't it on the list will be for example
legislative votes that's
actual law making but there are many
other votes
mixed in with resolutions scattered
around the chamber
will be whips they usually sit down the
front and they will indicate a thumbs up
or a thumbs down when they do a thumbs
down the arms usually go
like this in a parallel fashion because
if they go
straight up like this sometimes you
mistake it for like this
and don't forget the parliament is open
to the public and as you can see there's
lots of people everywhere so absolutely
anyone can watch all the shenanigans
going on in the hemi cycle even
lobbyists so long as they all play by
house rules
with the plenary over it's now time to
leave strasbourg but don't forget there
are also many plenaries back in brussels
but that's another story